so kristen is it true that your
six-year-old leaves you like nasty notes
around your house
oh sure
i think dad had said no we're not going
to ice cream which was why i was allowed
in but you know it's seven o'clock in
the evening we're not going to get ice
cream right now and then she decided she
was like well
i'm just going to starve myself today so
is it true though that your
three-year-old calls you a treat mom
treat mom yes because i guess i give him
a lot of treats he also calls me trash
mom too because i take all this that's
different sounding i'm both
i'm treat mom and trash bombs trash mom
is a whole different story
the way i was told that this was your
first trip away from your kids in a year
yeah is that how are you the week before
i go i have crazy migraines and
i mean i'm just i
it's like it's really really hard and
then all of a sudden i'm gone i'm
sitting on the plane
and i have six uninterrupted hours
and like just do nothing or
or all the things i want to do all the
time but never do i watched ocean's 11.
i listened to kelly clarkson congrat
good taste good deal yes i know no
that's that's awesome i was going to say
i have that dread it's it is
anticipatory because you're you're like
oh my god something's going to happen to
them i'm not going to be here like i
start dreading everything and then i get
on the plane i'm like this is amazing it
is and it's sad we're i'm heartbroken
like you know we shouldn't have guilt
when we like finally have time for
ourselves and i had a margarita yeah
like
i don't know one yeah it's five o'clock
somewhere exactly
great so we were talking about your kids
so what do they think of your tick tock
dance moves basically they think i'm the
worst and
i'm just like can i can i just remind
you that i'm honey i'm yeah
exactly
did you see the movie i mean ladies
and they're just like mom but when you
voted look at him
i have to say they had to think this was
pretty cool because you got zac efron in
20-year tick-tock videos so i want to
show this video real quick
so they had to have thought this was
amazing that you got him in did they
think you were cool they were like is he
coming over like how did you get him to
do this like does he think you're a
stalker like they were so confused about
how it happened and i was like i did a
job with him in dubai and by the way he
did a video with me yeah exactly i'm
literally even talking about it it's so
funny because my kids will be like you
know this person like yeah but they know
me too i'm like wait what and like our
kids our kids don't care yeah they have
no idea literally my kids the other day
they were fighting over so they because
they do that thing where there's a
little different like they know that if
we go to a store i said i prep them i
say we're going in this door and you're
not getting anything we're doing
something for somebody else or whatever
or i prep them and say hey if y'all want
to grab something like little you get
one little thing or something but i am
big on prepping them because if you
don't that's when the nightmare happens
and also they were fighting it over
something and they were so entitled like
y'all have so many toys and so i took
that toy
straight to the trash
that's what i'm talking about i was like
i was like i'm sorry since neither one
of you knows how to share it we will
give it to the garbage
like and it's gone until they go in the
garbage and get it oh they won't go in
the garbage they hate that i make them
shake the trash out oh no
joshua has pulled out many toys from the
garbage oh really i threw his ipad away
one day oh oh i went and got that out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but i had to teach him a
oh my lesson as soon as he went to bed i
was like don't let me forget that
well last time you were here you
announced that you were having a boy so
congrats
um so it was a rocky birth right it
ended up being hey well he was breached
so he was sideways and we had to do a
c-section and i was just like oh i
wasn't ready for this and he came out
with some breathing problems but after
like five so i met him over face time
but
um after five days we got to take him
home and he's so healthy and happy now
but it was a that skin to skin tone
i didn't get it i didn't get it for the
first like two days oh i will cry right
yeah so i was like i i was really hard
and i was like oh my god emotionally i
only got to see him over facetime and i
was like i mean i guess thank god i have
an iphone or something but like yeah we
are magical we're amazing we make humans
that's amazing
like amazing
central nervous system like that's
incredible and brains and like we're
like i don't know i truly i mean for me
i'm already like let's go again like
let's make i love that even like no
matter how like scary the birth was or
anything i'm like five more at least oh
i left well you're you love you're such
a big family and y'all are so tight
that's right you've had um another baby
this year you were just talking about so
that's i'm a mom as well in work as well
and that's a hard thing to balance are
you finding that hard i mean last night
i was up a good four times in the night
you know like are you waiting i put the
passion do i not
did you sleep train are you doing sleep
training you're in the midst of it oh
yeah hell yeah i am but my friend taught
me a trick to just put like 20 passes
around them so they just go like this
and then they find one so is it true
though that your three-year-old calls
you a treat mom treat mom yes because i
guess i give him a lot of treats and
he also calls me trash mom too because i
take all his trash that's different
sounding i'm both
i'm treat mom and trash bombs trash bomb
is a whole different story it's
literally like here i'm done that's why
he calls me trash oh i love oh yeah
my kids i'm like oh look at those legs
you have you can walk it on over
yourself yeah they're five and seven
minor little older but yeah i heard that
hillary duff did she host like an
entertainment play date like what
happened with your kids what happened
well hillary is a close friend and she
has a daughter who is six weeks younger
than gus and she's like super mom she
has three kids but she decided to start
hosting this music class at her house
and there's lots of other new moms in
our group meghan trainor and ashley
tisdale so it kind of became like a bit
of a thing but there's lots of other
people that have lots of other jobs in
this class but it's so much fun like
i think in this time of covid and you
know having a kid in the midst of a
pandemic like finding community to lean
on 100 be able to like have your kids
sort of start to grow up together but
also like and have those pods where your
kids can play with other kids for sure
it's so essential so i'm really grateful
that hillary has done us all this this
giant favor yeah yeah because it's a lot
to host something like that yeah that's
like your fault especially a mom of
three get it hillary done so kristin is
it true that your six-year-old leaves
you like nasty notes around your house
oh sure
yeah wait what doesn't it because my
seven you leave them threatening notes
my seven-year-old will believe knows but
they're always like hearts and like us
together no no no no no
no but i mean sometimes she will do that
like sometimes it'll be like and i love
you but most times it's about what stuff
is hers and what not to touch yeah this
one that you're looking at says don't
disturb delta is starving to death only
mom can come in so this was over i think
an ice cream trip that i was like no
it's seven o'clock in the evening we're
not going to get ice cream right now and
then she decided she was like well
i'm just gonna starve myself to death
this one says delta's cookie don't eat
it or else dot dot dot she's learning
punctuation
but look at the size of the cookie there
was one bite left i kind of love and
appreciate and respect the fact that
she's setting boundaries at a young age
i'm raising very strong women okay yeah
you had a a home birth um for your
second baby right for banks yeah and
four men and so for your second and
third yeah and why'd you want to do
homework because it kind of terrifies me
because i had complications so you never
know when you're gonna have
complications yeah you know what was
really cool about the home birth kelly
is like
you know you're bringing a baby into the
world that's some of the hardest work
anybody can do amen and they don't let
you have like water in the hospital or
food or snacks and you're about to like
work the hardest you've ever worked to
like push a baby out so at home you get
all oh i had sugar fish in bed i had a
glass of wine
i had sushi in my bed with my baby and a
glass of rose that i actually was
like clawing at the bit to have and i
took a sip afterwards and i was like
it's not doing it for me one of my
favorite memories was like luca decided
to sing may happy birthday
and i was like i've never heard of
anyone singing happy birthday on a
first birth like entering date but he
was like we should sing her happy
birthday and i was like i think that's
so precious
but has like being a mother like
caretaker for another for a child like
in real life did that help you out at
all in the role oh god yes i think the
question of what is a parent
is really important to me because we
have a narrative that says well when a
man and a woman get together in the
sperm of the egg you know all that stuff
and then you have the rest of the world
where there are
uh adoptions and through foster care and
all i mean that my family if it wasn't
for adoption and foster care i wouldn't
have my family yeah so there are
millions upon millions of babies and
children on this planet
that have no one to love and have no one
to make let them know that they're the
most amazing thing when they walk in the
room there are millions upon millions of
adults that wish they could be a parent
yeah and society is going well if you
are gay or if you are single or i'm like
love is love you know and if we stop
defining that narrative is just one
avenue
the amazing impact would be would be
love in families and health and mental
health and connection
[Music]
you